Community Pride on Las Vegas now is
sponsored by Findlay automotive group
Southwest Medical part of Optum care
Silver State Schools Credit Union and
then V Energy
[Music]
out by Subaru of Las Vegas to help
Findlay automotive group the sponsors of
this segment continue to share the love
we are here at findlay's Subaru of Las
Vegas and of course it is time to
continue sharing the love we are
celebrating cars and Community once
again Tyler how did it go this year Well
it went awesome and so and welcome to
Findlay Subaru of Las Vegas it's our
15th year of the Subaru share the love
event and one of the favorite things we
do every year that we do it a lot give
away money but this was one of our
favorite events is the share the love
where we get to get a lot of money to
some great deserving local charities so
that's what we're here for today okay
and what are the local charities so we
have with us today Red Rock search and
rescue and the just one project now the
Subaru share the love event is from
November to January this year we had
more cars that we were able to sell so
that raised the bar but you know the the
factory Subaru of America donated 250
dollars to one of four National
Charities or they split it depending on
what the customer chose and then we
added additional 75 dollars per vehicle
that we retailed for our local charities
and also 5 five dollars donated from us
every oil service that we did during
that period so you
love with these checks ready let's do it
all right all right so this is our
second year with just one project as one
of our featured Charities and this year
our check is a little bit larger and so
Brooke I'd like to present to you 32
397 dollars
[Applause]
let me come over to you Tyler I'm gonna
I'm gonna take your position here we've
got to talk to the queen here how are
you feeling I know you're shocked this
is just remarkable to be included in
this amazing event for the second year
it is just incredible and we are able to
serve so many Southern Nevada residents
with this generosity we're just blown
away truly we're blown away by your work
can you let everybody know what you do
at this one project absolutely the just
one project we connect the community
Through volunteerism while creating
access to Fresh groceries and wraparound
services and other resources for the
12th consecutive Year we're featuring
Red Rock search and rescue one of our
favorite Charities we have a nice check
for them this year to help them out so
uh with Zane I want to present to you a
check for thirty six thousand one
hundred and eighty nine dollars
incredible incredible thank you thank
you I appreciate it I gotta talk to Z
gray over here now what does this mean
to to you guys and you said 12 years
yeah it's really been a wonderful
cooperation between us and Subaru it's
been because of them that we can operate
the way we do and serve our community
with uh you know going out and searching
and finding lost loved ones and figuring
closure to families and it's been a
fantastic experience and without their
help we wouldn't be all operating to the
15th annual annual ruse share the love
of
events you are incredible Hometown
Charities congratulations
always good vibes there we want to thank
Findlay automotive group for being one
of our Community Pride Partners JC I'll
send it to you